in pittsburgh pennsylvania selling his
massive
2.25 trillion he calls it
infrastructure plan although a lot of it
isn't just about
roads bridges and tunnels a lot of it
has to do with race-based payments
a climate army places to plug in your
electric vehicle
but dana it's not just 2.25 trillion
this is just a start
he said he's got another 2 trillion
coming in the pipeline
how do you see this thing going well i
think it'll be probably pretty popular
right out of the gate
um and then as people start to learn
more about it it'll probably drop off
as you know he's coming out here he's
not going to get all that he wants
in this bill what's interesting is that
the chief of staff ron klein has had
so many meetings with the progressives
so forget that the republicans
might oppose it the progressive caucus
doesn't even like it because they say
it doesn't spend enough you know
yesterday we were talking about how
roads and bridges should be very popular
people like roads and bridges they want
their roads and bridges to be safe
if that's what was in this bill then you
probably could get bipartisan support
but there's a lot of other things in
here you mentioned a couple of them
i just want to mention one other thing
there's something in the bill called
the pro act and that would basically end
right to work
in 27 states which basically means that
keeps workers from having to pay union
dues basically
so that's pretty egregious right to use
yet again
a national bill to try to usurp state
laws this is what they're also trying to
do with hr1 when it comes to 35 states
that have voter id laws um if you care
about states rights and conservatives do
or used to no i'm kidding they do that
would be
another example of it um they're also
going to have a hard time with
with the taxes you have all of these
people in america that are
just getting back on their feet and back
to work and then all of a sudden you're
going to be hit with
a whole bunch of higher taxes and i
don't believe that it will only be taxes
on
people making four hundred thousand
dollars or more the corporate tax
increases
will definitely trickle down to all of
us everybody
rich and poor yeah degan i noticed him
taking a big swing at the corporate tax
policy
he's been in washington his whole life
he wrote that corporate tax policy
that let corporations go offshore and
take profits and build factories now
he's going to come in
and rearrange the game it just doesn't
it doesn't pass the smell test then he
takes a shot at the trump tax cuts
and said that didn't work out for the
middle class i believe the average
middle class family got a 5
000 raise in just three years under
donald trump
that was pretty historic uh
the vast majority of americans got a tax
cut
so it makes me steam and mad
when i hear people talk about the tax
cuts for the rich
from the trump tax cuts what the trump
tax cuts taken the corporate rate down
to 21
and deregulating large swaths of the
economy
what it did was rank and file workers
wages
were finally growing at a faster pace
than their bosses if they were growing
at the fast
before the pandemic the fastest pace in
at least
a decade for rank and file workers the
income inequality in this country
was shrinking the unemployment rate fell
to a 50-year low so joe biden is going
to reverse that
it is laughable to say oh we're only
raising the corporate tax rate back to
28
i pointed out yesterday that's higher
than china's
so if this is meant to make us better at
competing with china
that's a lie and it also takes the
corporate
it would push the u.s corporate tax rate
back to the top of the pack
among major economies but this was a
part this was hard to listen to
joe biden hacking up the word casserole
that he's been spoon fed
by his people over the last few days
quite frankly it
took weeks it reads better at least on
paper
than it did with him barfing it up which
was
neither not appetizing or palatable
but just a one quick thing i can we can
talk about the inflation implications
how this is going to hurt wage growth
how this is going to hurt job growth and
how with
six trillion dollars in spending so far
uh in the last year how that's going to
send prices skyrocketing and you
have too much money chasing too few
goods and services
you get stagflation it's like the 1970s
but before i go
his people might want to give him a
couple of sudafed and a red bull if he's
going to speak about five o'clock in the
afternoon
because he was fading i think he was
definitely faded from the flight to
pittsburgh there's no doubt about that
brian kilmeade long island guy you take
the train
you see the airports around here you
drive over the potholes
would you focus on that type of
infrastructure
or would you build a lot of electric car
charging stations for all the tesla
drivers on the lia
great question uh a couple of things
they did rebuild laguardia and he does
deserve credit for it he walked through
it one day when he was vice president
he mocked it and they have they have
rebuilt it the fact that everyone
stopped flying for a year
allowed them to accelerate it so it's
definitely a huge help i was just
speaking with kevin
brady while we were going over this we
have to stop looking at joe biden as a
uniter somebody who's in the middle of
the road who likes to bring people
together who's amiable
first he totally miscarried the georgia
uh voting bill
and said it was sick and it's totally
inaccurate even the washington post
called them out
then he just said this big tax cut that
trump not even president trump
but trump passed was only for the rich
where three of every four dollars
actually went to families where one
trillion dollars flew back
uh and flowed back into the united
states he's now upping
our corporate tax rate to equal with
syria as well as france
and he also said this is quote as i look
at this whole thing and what it's
spending on you mentioned green
technology
uh you mentioned that he's going to be
building uh he's going to be
retrofitting one million
buildings with what he's getting rid of
windows i believe
and now he's getting all these charging
stations he called it as it reads now
the biggest economic blunder in our
lifetime
and yeah i give him credit for colin
mitch mcconnell but
this whole first plan is problematic
because it's green oriented
i believe there should be some cognizant
ability to make that transition
we can't keep kidding ourselves we're
ready to get our fossil fuels but i'm
worried about the next one
the human infrastructure human
infrastructure seems like socialism guys
yeah and if they retrofit every single
building here in manhattan
i'm gonna have a headache with all the
hammering it's enough already